let's get to the questions the first one
came in from Dennis what is the most
successful path to take a customer from
signing up for your email list to
converting them to a paying customer is
there a certain path the process you
take that makes the entire transition
simple and painless for the customer wow
that is a great question and the answer
that is unfortunately no there's never
one single path that works for everyone
to help you flesh out that path or
figure out what that path maybe it takes
a lot of testing and it takes a lot of
tracking of what campaigns you're using
or what channels you're using so i can
tell you from my personal experience you
know working here at a weber is there's
never going to be a single path we
consider you know are a top number one
way of going what we do is we take
different approaches to different
campaigns to different target audiences
different channels and what we do at
that point is we'll start seeing what
the success is based on our acquisition
or a turn or retention so I'd love to
say that yes this is the path that works
best for everybody but unfortunately I
can ever tell that to you so it takes a
lot of testing it takes a lot of
information Dennis thank you for that
strong lead opening question there ah I
feel like so many entrepreneurs are told
they need a list right everybody says
you need to get an email list and it's
often one of the biggest regrets for a
lot of online marketers is that they
wish they had started sooner with having
a list uh but then you have a list of
what do you do with it right like how do
you I think a lot of entrepreneurs make
the mistake of i'm just going to blast
out promotions all day long and is that
yeah I mean it's best way the best way
to do is actually segment that list
right so you want to be smarter about
the content that you're sending out the
offers it's not going to relate back to
everybody else so when you're collecting
that list and this is for anyone who's
starting with email marketing or looking
to start an email list is um we have
certain features and functions with
another product that you can categorize
them right so you can look at maybe they
like a certain cupcake if you're into
pastries or they're certain movies they
love to talk about if you're doing some
kind of review that's the best way of
segmenting out your list at first and
just understanding what their specific
interest is and moving from there yeah
and i think it is with a general email
marketing strategy is providing content
and building a relationship first you
don't you don't walk up to somebody who
you just met and you know ask them to
marry you right you I hope nothing you
develop a relationship right you go on
dates you get to know them and that's
what you need to do with your your
customers who the people on your email
list they may come because they you know
saw some free download you had or they
write a post on your blog or they like
something about you but maybe not ready
to buy yet this is your chance to
develop an ongoing relationship with
them and you know one of the great
things about a weber is the
autoresponder sequence that you can
automatically send emails every week or
every three days or whatever time
interval you want to build a
relationship with them and offer them
lots of value before you start selling
anything so you could test it obviously
right that's the point of using data and
analytics just like you can test all the
things seven that's what it is yeah so
if i was looking at like a successful
path to take a customer the question was
from signing up to email is to convert
into the pain customer i look at an
autoresponder sequence that was full of
value that establish you as the expert
that you know you're talking about that
you're credible and then after that
sequence is through you can have a sales
pitch a call to action once they know
you like you trust you